salut qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
de la réincarnation je sais qu'il y en a
ils pensent qu'ils sont la réincarnation
d'Einstein de de Napoléon c'est rarement
d'ailleurs des réincarnations de
personnes normales toujours des
réincarnation de personnes brillantes
aujourd'hui on va parler de ça on va
surtout parler de quelqu'un qui est
soi-disant la réincarnation d'un énorme
illustre peintre il s'appelle
Toulouse-Lautrec on parlera en fin de
vidéo si vous voulez qu'on se donne un
peu notre avis sur le la réincarnation
on va d'abord se concentrer sur cette
histoire des années 50 une histoire se
passe dans une grande exploitation de
Californie où il y a une douzaine de
vaches qui travaillent donc s'occupe du
bétail dont William Lawrence rowens en
matière Lawrence avec l'accent français
qui travaille qui est le plus mauvais
d'ailleurs d'entre eux il a 35 ans il
habite dans la ferme où il a une petite
chambre pour lui il en sort pas beaucoup
il a un physique tout à fait normal
plutôt discret discret mais maladroit il
fait pas mal de bourdes c'est pas un bon
cavalier ils montent pas très bien
cheval quand c'est lui qui emmène le
bétail ça lui arrive de perdre des bêtes
alors pourquoi autant apprécié quand
même dans l'exploitation c'est parce que
il est rigoureux et loyal il est
toujours à l'heure il est il essaie
toujours de faire de son mieux il écoute
tous les ordres qu'on lui donne
contrairement aux autres vachés qui sont
meilleurs que lui mais qui sont un petit
peu plus autonome et un peu moins
fiables et je vous parle d'un jour
précis où William et asphalt il essaie
de faire rentrer le bétail dans l'enclos
il galère comme d'habitude les bêtes
prennent la mauvaise direction le
dirigeant le patron d'exploitation le
traite de bois rien bon ça se fâche tant
bien que mal il réussit à finir son
travail avec l'aide de l'exploitant du
propriétaire et il retourne à l'étable
pour y déposer son son cheval plus
précisément sa jument et quand tu montes
une jument il y a quelque chose qui ne
faut pas faire c'est croiser un étalon
parce que ça peut rendre la jument
nerveuse évidemment vous en doutez où il
y a va croiser un étalons parce qu'il
prend pas ça en compte manque de bol la
jument devient nerveuse et du coup elle
met à faire des ruées et elle les jette
et comme sur le sale la tête la première
il est pas mort mais il est très mal en
point il est amené à l'hôpital c'est là
que l'histoire de la réincarnation va
commencer l'histoire elle est
passionnante et elle va vous faire vous
poser plein de questions comme moi
d'ailleurs au fur et à mesure certaines
vont trouver la réponse mais si vous
aimez les histoires avant de poursuivre
je vais prendre quelques secondes pour
vous présenter le sponsor du jour la des
histoires vous allez en avoir parce que
le sponsor du jour c'est parce que le
sponsor du jour c'est Crunchyroll
Crunchyroll c'est la plus grande
plateforme d'animaux au monde où vous
pouvez retrouver toute une très vaste
bibliothèque d'animés sous-titrée
professionnellement en français mais
aussi dans différents genres ça veut
dire des animés d'action d'aventure de
comédie de drame de romance de
science-fiction de fantastique bref vous
avez tous les genres
et vous pouvez y retrouver les animés du
moment en exclusivité l'attaque des
Titans
jujutsukaisen ou encore demon Slayer
parce que je vous rappelle quand même
que je suis moi-même le casse-tête
Slayer
[Musique]
le petit plus c'est que vous pouvez
aussi regarder les derniers épisodes
d'animer quelques heures après leur
diffusion au Japon et ça en vrai c'est
vraiment génial pour profiter de tout ça
Crunchyroll vous propose trois
abonnements pas un pas deux mais trois
différents allant de 4,99 par mois à 64
99 par an évidemment avec le forfait
megaphone qui vous donne accès à tout le
catalogue en illimité sans publicité et
qui vous permet aussi de partager votre
abonnement jusqu'à 4 écrans en simultané
avec en plus de tout ça un mode hors
ligne qui va vous permettre de regarder
vos épisodes même sans réseau Quand tu
es dans le train par exemple et que tu
as pas de réseau
bref vous laisse aller découvrir
Crunchyroll via le lien dans la
description en ce moment vous pouvez
bénéficier d'un essai gratuit d'un mois
en passant par mon lien donc on fait
quoi on en profite et petit bonus du
coup comme je suis le casse-tête Slayer
n'hésitez pas à regarder Damon Slayer je
vous garantis vous n'allez pas le
regretter je joue pas dedans
malheureusement je comprends pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs finalement rien de
très grave à l'hôpital pour oublieram
Lawrens souvenez-vous il est tombé à
cheval mais il s'est réveillé rapidement
son état est plutôt correct par contre
il y a un truc très étrange il demande
immédiatement à l'infirmière qu'elle lui
apporte des toiles des pinceaux de la
peinture de quoi peindre l'infirmière va
s'exécuter mais elle va quand même
prévenir le docteur le docteur Shepard
qui s'inquiète un petit peu pour son
état et ses demandes un peu étranges et
qui va commencer à lui donner des
tranquillisants et l'état de santé de
William est plutôt bonne il n'y a pas de
fracture par chance il y a aucune
couplusion cérébrale ou ce genre de
choses juste tous les jours il demande
encore des toiles des pinceaux de la
peinture et il affirme que c'est le seul
moyen qu'il est pour savoir qu'il est
parce qu'il a l'air amnésique qui se
souvient plus de sa propre histoire et
il affirme à tout le monde que son
identité et son histoire est là dedans
caché dans un coin de son cerveau et
qu'il n'y a pas encore accès et les
infirmières lui disent ah non vous êtes
vous êtes mâché vous habitez dans une
ferme il fait non non non c'est
impossible c'est impensable c'est pas ça
ma vie et c'est pas la personne que je
suis et il y a quand même un fait un peu
troublant c'est qu'il utilise un langage
très sophistiqué craignant c'est du
vocabulaire un petit peu de la haute en
tout cas clairement pas le langage d'un
dashi alors le personnel médical
s'exécute et lui donne de quoi peindre
vraiment toutes les toiles qu'ils ont
trouvé à disposition tout la peinture
tous les pinceaux et là William rentre
dans une sorte de frénésie un truc un
petit peu compulsif et il va parler de
la peindre des danseuses des hommes
du French Cancan des scènes de
personnages en haute forme il va faire
une toile immense et il va signer la
toile à la toute fin ce sera son dernier
coup de pinceau en bas à droite il va
marquer Toulouse Lautrec pour William
Laurens ça fait aucun doute il est
Toulouse-Lautrec et attention il dit pas
qu'il est l'instantanément il dit qu'il
est sa réincarnation que
Toulouse-Lautrec est en lui et vous
verrez que cette nuance elle fait sens
et elle a un intérêt précis plus tard
dans l'histoire si vous n'êtes pas des
grands ferreux de peinture vous avez
peut-être déjà entendu Toulouse-Lautrec
soit son nom soit parce que une place
porte son nom c'est un peintre qui a
autant de reconnaissance aujourd'hui
qu'un Picasso par exemple alors une fois
qu'il va aller mieux il va pas repartir
à la ferme il part à San Francisco il
s'installe là-bas il se construit un
petit atelier il commence à peindre les
signes toujours l'étoile
Toulouse-Lautrec et et tous San
Francisco commence à s'intéresser en
fait à son travail parce que l'étoile
sont très belles le coup de pinceau est
vraiment le même coup de pinceau que
Toulouse Lautrec alors ici une bien
évidemment tout le trek mais toujours en
prétendant et en expliquant qu'il est sa
réincarnation et beaucoup à San
Francisco même dans les marchands
comment ça le croit jusqu'au jour où il
est en train de peindre dans son atelier
ça frappe à la porte il ouvre une
personne se présente comme étant Georges
obrady alors vous connaissez pas mais à
l'époque son nom là est très connu dans
ce milieu là c'est le plus grand
marchand d'art et il possède la plus
grande galerie de Californie genre
obrady lui il découvre pas le vacher
combien avait expliqué le petit gringalé
un petit peu timide qu'essayer surtout
de ne pas être vu y découvre un jeune
homme avec une barbe de trois jours avec
les cheveux longs qui sent l'alcool et
qui visiblement ne sort jamais de son
atelier c'était le cas il sortait jamais
y passer ses journées à peindre et
refuser toutes les visites d'ailleurs au
moment où il ouvre la porte à la base
c'est pour dire la personne qui frappe
de ne rencontrer mais là intrigué par le
nom qui vient d'entendre il le fait
rentrer il discute un petit peu Georges
Brady va lui dire je ne crois pas du
tout en votre histoire de réincarnation
moi je pense que vous êtes un faussaire
mais par contre je pense que tout le
monde y croit et ça ça m'intéresse alors
il dit voici le marché si vous me donnez
l'exclusivité sur toutes les œuvres que
vous peignez quand un vrai style mais
qui sont pour moi des imitations et bien
dans ce cas là je vais pas les revendre
au prix qu'on vendrait un vrai
Toulouse-Lautrec on l'affirmera jamais
ça par contre je suis presque certain
que je peux faire de vous un homme riche
et William Lorenz va accepter Lauren se
peint et pluie pas un plus haut Brady
vent de toiles et plus au bras divan
d'étoiles plus Lorraine se met à peindre
et ils inondent complètement le marché
de l'art ça agace certaines personnes ça
agace certains puristes et l'association
des musées de la ville décide de tout
stopper en portant plainte contre
William Lawrence pour titre de faussaire
nous sommes précisément le 16 septembre
1954 le procès va avoir lieu William
Lawrens se rend au tribunal
correctionnel de New York il a fait du
trajet pour venir il arrive dans un état
lamentable ses vêtements sont sales il
sent mauvais il a les yeux vitreux
vraiment on pense qu'il est alcoolisé il
a les cheveux longs en pagaille une
barbe qui ressemble le plus à rien il
est même secoué de sorte de pathétique
nerveux là mais de type nerveux pas de
surprise la partie civile commence à
étayer son argumentation mais elle
conclut en affirmant que Williams
Lawrence est un faussaire et qu'il vend
des toiles qu'il fait passer pour de
véritables Toulouse-Lautrec et qu'il
faut le condamner pour ça la
démonstration est brillante rien n'a été
oubliée aucun détail et pourtant la
défense sourit patiemment dans son coin
pendant toutes les explications de la
partie civile pourquoi parce que lors
des France elle va tenir en une chose
mais de taille elle dit oui tout ce qui
a été dit a été vrai sauf un point notre
client n'a jamais affirmé que cette fois
[Musique]
une nouvelle fait sensation William
Laurens peut du coup continuer à peindre
mais en plus de ça ça lui fait une promo
de fou c'est à dire qu'avant c'était
tous San Francisco un petit peu New York
qui parlait de lui là ce sont tous les
États-Unis qui parlent de lui qui
s'intéresse à ses toiles et qui se pose
la grande question est-ce que vraiment
c'est la réincarnation de
Toulouse-Lautrec ou est-ce qu'il fait
bulle et ça va défiler à l'atelier à
tout le monde y va les journalistes
essaient d'avoir un contact avec lui il
veut pas les recevoir des médiums des
spécialistes de l'occultisme vont
vouloir le rencontrer pour voir si oui
ou non il y a le fantôme de Lautrec en
lui ou est-ce qu'il y a une
réincarnation en tout cas par curiosité
ou parfois pour prétendre pouvoir
démêler le vrai du faux eux aussi voudra
pas les recevoir en tout cas c'est pas
compliqué il ne veut voir que George
obradi est personne d'autre et pourtant
ils vont pas se voir souvent à part pour
certaines livraisons et encore souvent
le transport est assuré par des tiers
que Georges obrady qui va pas faire ce
travail là lui-même Jean obrady va
néanmoins le voir une fois le 8 avril
1955 il trouve William Lorenza c'est un
état lamentable très fortement alcoolisé
dans un état physique et pire que ce
qu'il a connu avant de William Laurens
l'atelier c'est un cafard c'est un
désordre sans nom les dernières toiles
sont même pas terribles de coups de
pinceau comment ça se perdre on est sur
une échéance sauf qu'avec le temps
George au Brady au-delà du business il
s'est pris d'affection pour vous William
Laurens et il lui demande en fait de lui
promettre d'arrêter de boire et de se
prendre en main il fait pas ça pour
sauvegarder son business il fait ça
parce que il sait qu'il est le seul ami
de William Lawrens et il sait qu'au fond
ce type là et archip type alors au Brady
va pas aller par quatre chemins il lui
dit écoute William tu as été très fort
avec ton histoire de réincarnation
franchement c'était un coup de génie
parce que du coup tu as pu peindre sans
jamais être inquiété ou Traité de
faussaire mais visiblement tu le vis mal
ça te rend malade et je pense que c'est
ça qui fait que tu te plonge dans cet
alcoolisme à cause de ce mensonge alors
tu sais quoi il faut que tu peignes dans
ton nom maintenant faut que tu arrêtes
avec cette histoire de réincarnation il
faut que tu dises que le don tu es passé
où tu t'es trompé ou ce que tu veux tu
as gagné énormément d'argent de quoi
vivre toute ta vie sans jamais
t'inquiéter du futur ou de tes ressorts
financières donc débarrasse-toi de ça
débarrasse toi de cette histoire
derrière incarnation peu importe toi si
tu as envie de peindre mais arrête de te
rendre malade avec cette histoire sauf
que Lorenz affirme toujours et
Toulouse-Lautrec il dit non non je suis
Toulouse le trac mais il inquiet pour
une autre raison Toulouse-Lautrec est
mort à 36 ans et Lorenz vient de fêter
ses 36 ans très récemment le 6 juillet
1954 à la une des journaux on apprend
que William Laurens a été retrouvé mort
il s'est jeté du Golden Gate à San
Francisco volontairement c'est pas un
accident et on a retrouvé son cadavre
les autorités se rendent à son atelier
et ils vont retrouver tout un livret
contenant les confessions de William
Lawrens tout ce qu'il avait à dire avant
de commettre l'irréparables et la
première chose qu'il est dit dans ses
confessions c'est que Georges obrady
avait raison il avait inventé toute
cette histoire de bout en bout dans un
seul but gagner de l'argent et
d'explique à quel point il était étonné
que personne s'en soit rendu compte
avant d'être bâché William Laurens en
réalité à Paris il étudie aux Beaux-Arts
et à sa sortie de l'école personne était
intéressée par ses toiles tout le monde
de trouver un peu basique voire minable
sauf certains acheteurs qui étaient très
intéressés par ces reproductions parce
qu'à priori il avait un talent pour
reproduire les toiles des grands maîtres
sans en faire des fours évidemment juste
pour faire de la reproduction en
particulier il arrivait assez bien à
calquer le style et le coup de pinceau
de Toulouse le trek lui ça l'intéressait
pas donc il est rentré aux États-Unis et
il a été prendre ce petit job de Vacher
pour un peu enfouir et intérêt et ses
rêves d'être un jour un grand peintre
jusqu'au jour où il a fait sa chute à
cheval qui était pas prémédité et quand
il s'est réveillé à l'hôpital qu'on lui
a dit qu'il avait chuté à cheval ça lui
a rappelé la chute qui avait fait
Toulouse l'autre et lui-même quand il
était petit et c'est là qu'il a eu
l'idée de se dire et si je faisais
croire que je venais d'être inspiré par
Toulouse-Lautrec au début pour lui
c'était un jeu il jouait la comédie et
au fur et à mesure il s'est pris à son
propre piège jusqu'à parfois l'alcool
aidant se poser des questions
elle était vraiment à la réincarnation
ou pas et à la fin il a joué son propre
jeu jusqu'au bout il s'est dit puisque
je suis Toulouse-Lautrec je vais mourir
comme Toulouse-Lautrec George obrady
avait aussi les clés de l'atelier donc
ici est rendu après après le décès de
William Laurens et il a retrouvé plein
de toiles qui étaient pas encore signé
Toulouse le trek et d'autres toiles qui
n'avaient rien à voir qui était les
toiles vraiment de ce que mes peindre
William Lawrence et là où c'est dommage
c'est que Georges obradi dira que
William Laurens avait beaucoup de talent
personnels et qu'il aurait pu devenir un
grand peintre en son style et dans son
monde
ce qui est étonnant avec cette histoire
même si on a touché à la fin de ce qu'on
connaît c'est que encore aujourd'hui il
y a des personnes qui se demandent si
dans le fond est-ce que c'était pas
vraiment la réincarnation c'est à dire
que tout en sachant que William Laurens
lui-même savait que ce qu'il disait
était une invention de sa part puisque
son style était si proche et si précis
de même le geste en soi du coup de
pinceau du maître Toulouse-Lautrec
est-ce qu'il était pas vraiment la
réincarnation et est-ce que c'est pas ça
en fait qu'il le perturbait tellement de
croire qu'il joue à un jeu alors que
c'était pas un jeu et qu'il était
vraiment la réincarnation de
Toulouse-Lautrec à titre personnel je
crois pas en la réincarnation de en tout
cas pas celle qu'on entend ça va toucher
à la spiritualité mais rationnellement
je pense pas que l'esprit de quelqu'un
avec ses compétences avec toutes ses
vies etc puisse se retrouver dans une
autre personne d'ailleurs pour un truc
très simple je n'y en a tellement de
mains sur terre que en fait du coup
c'est quoi c'est qu'il y a des nouveaux
humains ou des trucs comme ça bon je j'y
connais pas grand chose mais pour moi
c'est une question plus spirituelle que
rationnelle donc non par contre le fait
que lui s'en soit persuadé peut-être un
petit peu comme l'effet barnum ou
l'effet placebo malgré lui il est devenu
meilleur parce qu'au fond de lui il
croyait que peut-être c'est un petit peu
vrai et si vous aimez ces histoires là
les laisser raides un petit peu à
l'ancienne à la belle marge vous aimez
dans la description tous les anciens
épisodes qu'on avait fait il y a une
playlist aussi parfois vous me demandez
dans les commentaires où elles sont les
autres histoires dans la description et
en playlist merci beaucoup à Crunchyroll
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo des
histoires vous allez en trouver plein
chez eux vous avez tous les liens dans
la description et si vous voulez encore
deux autres histoires d'escroquerie je
vous en mets deux autres ici rien à voir
enfin celle-ci est intéressante mais
celle-ci c'est carrément l'escroc qui
s'est fait escroquer pensez à vous
abonner moi je m'appelle toujours Fabien
olicard à très bientôt Ciao